[Musique]
il
dans ce parc qui a la saveur de l'hiver
se trouve l'une des bonnes tables de
franche comté et c'est là dans les
coulisses du restaurant que la
dégustation commence ici chaque jour se
déroule un spectacle inconnu du grand
public
[Musique]
en cuisine au sein de la brigade le
pâtissier semble toujours navigué en
solitaire
julien ivan s est un pro du dessert un
accro du cacao
impensable d'imaginer 400 danseurs en
chocolat oui tout à fait c'est
impensable
je pense que le chocolat c'est
c'est la vie pour moi c'est le coin ça
restera passe de la pâtisserie pour
le chef du restaurant tony serre a fait
lui entièrement confiance à ce pâtissier
qui doit en permanence renouveler la
recette du bonheur
[Musique]
ça gêne et tartelettes au chocolat avec
2 200 heures différentes le chocolat
noir avec le chocolat blanc ensuite
dessus j'ai posé une tuile délicatement
croquante aux crues et de cacao est ce
que nous trouvons dessus c'est une
goutte au chocolat noir de 64 % de cacao
avec un coeur crème brûlée à la vanille
que les gens aiment encore être bien
rassuré sur le dessert moi je serais
plutôt un peu fou fou mais je crois
qu'on essaie d'incorporer quand même des
petites touches un peu rigolote qui
peuvent un peu surprendre le palais
quand même tout en restant raisonnable
et les gens ils peuvent retrouver le
goût de chocolat du vrai chocolat
mais si nous sommes allés au château de
la dame blanche c'est parce que c'est
sans doute l'un des rares en france à
proposer une petite douceur très
nourrissante pour le corps comme pour
l'esprit
c'est donc on dit massage au chocolat
mais en fin de compte c'est une poudre
de cacao qui est mélangé ou une huile ou
une crème et en l'occurrence ici c'est
une crème qu'on chauffe
tu as également à l'intérieur du cacao
des tanins qui sont les polyphénols et
là c'est des antioxydants hyper puissant
qui vont lutter contre le vieillissement
de la peau donc après qui va avoir une
peau toute belle toute seule et vous
avez plus en plus de demandes pour le
chocolat ça dépend c'est bizarre il ya
des fois c'est ça va être que salée puis
à des fois ça va stopper
et puis il ya ce coup ça repart voilà on
ne sait pas pourquoi les des moments ça
doit dépendre de l'humeur des gens un
massage gourmand et pas trop collant
selon la cliente alors le chocolat a
très très bien
une ode aux deux chocolats qui remplit
vraiment de bonheur et c'est vraiment ce
qu'on retient du massage en dehors du
travail accompli par la masseuse c'est
vraiment l'odeur du chocolat qu'on
retient
élue joueuse en jeu oui beaucoup
des expériences sensorielles autour du
chocolat il en existe d'autres
l'une des plus surprenantes et des plus
chics se trouve en bourgogne à beaune où
l'on excellent depuis longtemps dans
l'art de flatter le palais
[Musique]
e